Щиро вітаємо вас у програмі У фокусі
Європа нинішні літо завдає нам
європейцям досить Великого клопоту
величезна спека брак дощу багато вогню
лісові пожежі як правило вирують у сухих
південних частинах континенту але цього
року від позахи та пожеж постраждала
також і значна частина центральної та
Північної Європи води стає дедалі менше
особливо це стосується Сонячної Та
сухоїспанії де вирощують більшість
європейських фруктів та овочів перш ніж
вони потраплять у супермаркет
знадобиться багато води яку більшість
фермерів добувають незаконно через
величезну спрагу сільського господарства
ванделусі на півдні Іспанії
водно-болотним угіддям національного
парку доньяна загрожує засуха
цим колпицям стає тісно
Філіпа фуентельсас і пан Ромео
стурбовані екологи непокоїться за
існування сотень тисяч водоплавних
птахів у болотах доньяни що на крайньому
півдні Іспанії
рівень води падає
[музика]
для біорізноманіття Це катастрофа Хоча
ця територія охороняється заповідник
доньяна вже два роки майже сухий велике
водно-болотне угіддя немає води тому що
вона витрачається даремно у багатьох
випадках навіть не законно
[музика]
доньяна національний парк об’єкт
всесвітньої спадщини Юнеско оточений
фермами які зрошують свої плантації
полуниці ожини та малини грунтовими
водами
філіпи приніс карту червоні ділянки це
посівні площі які виникли тут з 1980-х
років без ліцензії
свердловин було пробурено посеред лісу
без жодного дозволу адміністрації
віднеслися до цього халатно ніхто не
зупинив це неконтрольоване зростання
Хуан хочу показати нам незаконні
свердловини йому відома ситуація
фермерів роками Вони чекають на
підключення до зрошувальної системи яка
транспортує воду в регіон із віддалених
річок
доти вони будуть використовувати ці
свердловини Але не всі мають на це
дозвіл
Тут спалахнули війна заводу війна за
дефіцитний ресурс мова йде про те хто
отримає її більше ось у чому проблема
раптом Лісова пожежа внаслідок тривалої
засухи при 43 градусній спеці це іронії
долі у цій місцевості пан виявляє яму з
водою
цей колодязь збудований незаконно без
документів
дуже близько до високого русла річки
тобто до державної власності
багато полів у цьому регіоні не мають
дозволу
фермери просто зробили з лісу чи Лугів
посівні площі ми хочемо з ними
поговорити але всі відмовляються навіть
фермери і здійснює ліцензію не хочуть
говорити на камеру занадто напружений
настрій вони надсилають речника мануеля
дельгадо Він переживає за гарне ім'я
місцевого сільського господарства на
Європейських ринках
нам загрожує поганий Імідж бо через
односторонні уявлення споживач може
подумати що всі фрукти вирощують
нелегально хоча насправді це не так
але це ще не все консервативна Народна
Партія
оголосила своєрідну амністію за
незаконне вирощування це розпалює
суперечку серед фермерів
цих фермерів слід покарати та площі
звільнити натомість робляться навпаки їх
винагороджують після 18 років незаконно
вирощування тепер вони мають отримати
дозвіл
це дратує також і екологи зокрема хуана
Тим більше що народну партію лише
нещодавно обрали абсолютною більшістю до
регіонального парламенту Андалусії Хуан
боїться що вона зможе здійснити те що
оголосила
партії яка керуватиме нами вандалузі
пообіцяла все легалізувати тому
адміністрації спочатку вичікують і не
переслідують за порушення Закону інакше
через занадто високе сподівання вони
спричинили величезне ажіотаж
цю критику він зрозуміти не може Мануель
Андреас Гонсалес депутат від партійнор у
вандалусії через амністію його партія
хоче забезпечити підключення всіх
посівних площ до майбутньої зрошувальної
системи
Так ми досягаємо двох цілей ми регулюємо
та гарантуємо що ґрунтові води більше не
видобуватимуться після того як
іспанський уряд нарешті виконає свій
обов'язок і збудує зрошувальні
трубопроводи
еколог Хуан бачить за всім цим лише
політичне перетягування каната і
економічні інтереси за рахунок природи
вони хочуть рости і рости поки природний
заповідник доньяна повністю не зникне ми
це бачимо замість заболоченої місцевості
у нас тут степ пустеля
[музика]
тепер у боротьбу за заповідник
втручається навіть єврокомісія і висуває
Іспанії останні Ультиматум якщо доньяна
буде знищуватися і надалі а водомістки
сільське господарство зростатиме країні
загрожують великі штрафи для цієї
колпиці це можливо останній шанс
[музика]
як це коли раптом а вдаряють ракети все
навколо тебе нищиться А тобі все ж
вдається вибратися в безпечне місце цей
жах переживають зараз люди в Нікополі на
Південному Сході України місто є одним
із прикладів потужних обстрілів з боку
російських військ військовий фотограф
оран Річардсон зафіксував на камеру те
що відбувається в Нікополі Він
представляє людей батьківщину яких та
їхні сім'ї забрала війна Він показує
обличчя війни
і ця війна Росії в Європі вже давно
розпалила також боротьбу за газ наразі з
Росії надходить значно менша газу ніж
домовлено і попри те що багато
європейців хотіли повністю відмовитись
від цих поставок без них наступна зима
буде досить холодною пошук альтернатив
іде повним ходом наразі Нідерландів
розглядають можливість А продовження
експлуатації найбільшого в Європі
газового родовища на північному сході
країни поблизу гронінгена глибоко в
землі лежить величезна кількість газу
але всі хто там живе платять за його
видобуток високу ціну
будинок Яна мунники роками був суцільним
будівельним майданчиком землетруси його
сильно пошкодили
ця частина будівлі вже відремонтована
можна бачити важкі залізні балки які
скріплюють стіну та внутрішню
конструкцію будівлі
іншу частину будинку довелося повністю
знести і зараз її відбудовують видобуток
газу у гронінгені десятиліттями
спричинює струси будинок постраждав від
сильного землетрусу у 2012 році
Це було жахливо це ворушилося вібрувало
величезний шум
був також і вибух
один раз
Так це велика втрата адже це був гарний
будинок Він нам подобався
землетрус ледь не зруйнував столітній
сарай зараз його дах укріплений
сталевими балками
землетрусу в регіоні відбуваються з
1980-х років муники веде про це записи
підземні поштовхи позначені червоним
кольором були сильними деякі привищували
три бали за шкалою рігтера
я почав записувати у 1994 році і
припинив у 2015 році скільки їх було так
багато що таблиця сягнула в підлоги
наразі від власників пошкоджених
будинків надійшло понад 160 тисяч
позовів про відшкодування збитків тож
уряд Нідерландів фактично вирішив
зменшити видобуток газу та закрити
газове родовище у 2023 році але
вторгнення Росії в Україну та збій
поставок газу до Європи ставлять ці
плани під сумнів уряд Нідерландів
нещодавно заявив що в разі надзвичайної
ситуації з газом узимку він може
повернутися до видобутку запасів з
газового родовища макіяль мюлдер експерт
із енергетики в університеті гронінгена
Він каже що збільшити видобуток із
газового родовища можна навіть тимчасово
і отримати схвалення місцевих жителів
вартість яку можна отримати на ринку від
виробництва та продажу газу з гронінгена
величезна лише невелику частину цього
доходу витратять на компенсацію збитків
всім жителям регіону гронінгенга через
підвищений ризик землетрусів адже вони
все ще трапляються це може бути
найкращим рішенням для всіх нас
У нас є тріщини в стіні а також на стелі
мар’ян Тур'є цим обіцянкам не довіряє
швидка її відповідна компенсація була б
для них абсолютно новим досвідом
які багато інших постраждалих вона
роками просить владу визнати та
відшкодувати збитки завдані видобутком
газу
або якщо потрібно знести будинок адже
нові землетруси лише посилюють старі
пошкодження
пошкоджень тут багато і це лякає людей а
вони бояться що в наступних землетрус
може призвести до того щоб валиться дах
і на них впадуть балки
тема газу викликала у Нідерландах
бурхливі дебати щодо майбутнього
енергозабезпечення
місцева Зелена Джастін Джонсон вбачає у
кризі можливість розвивати альтернативні
джерела енергії щоб раз і назавжди
закрити газове родовище у бронінгені
видобуток викупного палива пов'язаний з
втратами з втратами для людей втратами
для природи люди думають що якщо ми не
добуватимемо газ землетрусів більше не
буде
але навіть якщо ми дотримаємося терміну
встановленого урядом одна проблема В нас
усе ще залишиться Нам не слід
продовжувати видобуток інакше наслідки
триватимуть я муники отримав фінансову
компенсацію за відбудову свого будинку
лише через 10 років він каже що після
завершення видобутку в цій місцевості ще
деякий час будуть відбуватися землетруси
впродовж кількох місяців трусять потім
досить спокійно тоді новий землетрус
нові збитки треба про них знову заявляти
І весь цирк починається з початку
наразі держава Нідерланди та оператор
газового родовища виплатили постраждалим
1 мільярд євро Ніхто з мешканців тут не
вітатиме продовження видобутку газу але
якщо взимку газова криза загостриться то
можливо іншого виходу в уряду
Нідерландів не буде
захист дітей - це завдання сім'ї а також
держави адже мова йде про благо дитини
якщо здається що вона в небезпеці
данська держава вдається до очевидюсе
жорсткіших заходів зокрема у випадку
ханне хюрд в неї забрали дитину спільна
практика яку зараз там гаряче
обговорюють адже деякі данці навіть
утікають з дітьми за кордон щоб шукати
там захисту ханних Йорк та її чоловік
зараз також живуть у Німеччині звідти
Вони борються за те щоб їхня маленька
донька знову Була з ними
на обличчі ханних йорд досі помітний
переляк
це сталося два роки тому Данка разом із
сім'єю прямувала до Німеччини
на данському КПП шлях їм перегородили
поліцейським
йшлося про їхню доньку флору
Так у нас протримали більше трьох годин
так і не пояснивши в чому річ
наш страх і паніка зростали з кожною
хвилиною це важко описати Коли стало
зрозуміло що у рідних батьків відберуть
18-місячну дитину І абсолютно чужі люди
відвезуть її у прийомну сім’ю
[музика]
від доньки флори у Ханна залишилися лише
фотографії зараз дитина живе у прийомній
сім'ї у Данії
згідно із аргументацією добробут дитини
був під гострою загрозою Влада рідного
міста ханне віборг стверджує що вона та
її чоловік Кім недостатньо піклувалася
профлору
ним бажанням віддала свою першу дитину в
прийомну сім'ю тому що я була ще дуже
юною вони мабуть поставили на мені
клейму експерт служби у справах молоді
з'ясувала що Флора робила незвичайні
рухи в сторону і видавала схожі на
хрюкання звуки ми водили її до лікаря і
він не знайшов ні нічого незвичайного
але в адміністрації не змінили своє
рішення і все більше ускладнювали нам
життя їх не влаштовувало нічого з того
що ми робили
зараз сім'я живе у місті Фленсбург на
півночі Німеччини бо вони бояться за
свою молодшу доньку Ельвіру
ким має постійно роботу Хан не закінчує
заочне навчання однак вони побоюються що
якщо повернуться до Данії то в них
можуть забрати і Ельвіру
[музика]
на відстані всього двох годин їздив у
Данії у своєму саду сидить Ларс
крістіансен і розмовляє по телефону
відтоді як Крістіан син став свідком
того як забирають дітей у травмованих
данських солдатів він активно допомагає
людям виїхати
інколи я отримую від двох до трьох
дзвінків на день від людей які бояться
що їхніх дітей примусово усиновлять
Я раджу їм їхати за кордон адже до
прийняття остаточного адміністративного
рішення щодо долі дитини виїхати з
країни можна законно
місцева адміністрація ханних Йорк не
була готова до жодних коментарів
Міністерство соціальних справ Данії
написало Що шкодує про те що данські
сім'ї та їхні діти втікають за кордон
але захист дітей стоїть на першому місці
у міськраді фленсбурга зі змішаними
почуттями спостерігають за тим що все
більше данських сімей шукають у них
притулку від своїх соціальних органів
ми не вербуємо ми не говоримо
приїжджайте сюди тут чудові умови але
якщо хтось приїжджає до фрезбурга і ми
отримуємо документи які показують що
якусь справу необхідну супроводжувати
тоді ми звичайно повинні займатися цими
справами Оскільки ми переконані що
дитині добре коли вона росте у своїй
сім'ї
по той бік кордону у Данії служби
соціального захисту молоді захищаються
від звинувачень у жорстокості
у їхніх щоденній роботі заходи примусу є
великим винятком кажуть сімейні
помічники
ми спостерігаємо що дебати про примусове
усиновлення призвели до того що деякі
батьки бояться звертатися за допомогою
до служби у справах молоді
ми про це дуже шкодуємо тому що рішення
соціальної служби можна оскаржити і якщо
рішення чергової інстанції не влаштовує
то можна звернутися до суду
ханне це і зробила слухання мають
відбутися у вересні
але вона втратила будь-яку довіру до
данської держави
фленсбурзі вони отримали новий шанс
приємно зустріти людей які розуміють
тебе навіть якщо ти маєш іншу думку
вдома ми Цього ніколи не відчували
[музика]
Ханна таким чекають нас ще одну дитину
вони хочуть довести що можуть бути
хорошими батьками
багато сонця мало цінні спека цього літа
докучає також і в Парижі у багатьох
куточках французької столиці є принаймні
місця де можна у освіжитися численні
водозбірні колонки забезпечують парижан
прохолодної питною водою а з цього літа
також і багато екологічно свідомих
власників магазинів
Ось так Це налагоджено в Парижі але
цього спекотного літа така ідея була б
корисною також і для інших міст у
будь-якому разі ми бажаємо вам гарних
літніх днів і прощаємося з вами до
наступного тижня до побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив переклад Володимира та Олесі
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко текст читали
Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та Олесь
гоян Київ 2022 рік
[музика]